hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in section two of the ethics of
ambiguity simone de bois
analyzes a number of different types
of people who are you could say
making a bad use or an inauthentic use
of their own fundamental
human freedom and the third of these
is the nihilist this is a term that has
been used
in a number of different usually related
ways
so we should pause for a moment and talk
a little bit about
where she's getting this term from and
what
she means by it now some of that will be
revealed in the analysis
itself but we should remark that
nihilism
is a term that although it goes back to
the late 18th century
it doesn't really make its way into
european culture
until the mid part of the the 19th
century
and it's used for i mean it's coming
from latin
knee hill meaning nothing so it's used
for some sort of
relationship of the human being to
nothingness
and in a very broad sense it can be used
for those who are
contesting tearing down rejecting
conventional values and understandings
of the human condition
of society of morality doesn't
necessarily
mean a you know worshipping or
believing in nothing some of the early
russian nihilists
um talk that way others you know seem to
have
an appreciation for science at least in
a
useful sense uh that a pure nihilism
would probably go against
and it's often used now switching a
little bit you know further ahead it's
often used as a term
of critique or derision
by people who want to say that this
group over here by not respecting
certain values are not believing in any
values whatsoever
and that's that's sometimes the case and
sometimes
not the case nietzsche identified
nihilism as the great problem
for the 20th century for the century to
come from his point of view
de bevoir thinks that there are a lot of
different types
of nihilism or different modes of
nihilism but they come back to the same
basic problematic
so she talks about nihilism as
at least in some sense disappointed
seriousness that has turned back
on itself and what do we mean by
seriousness well the serious person
takes some sort of value and it's a
value that they received
not by deriving it themselves
but by getting it from somebody else and
they elevate it into an absolute or
something that is unconditioned they
orient their own comportment
decision making advocacy around that
subordinate everything else to it
there's a bit of a trade-off
they get to view themselves as being the
person who's
really in the know and the person who's
defending the the really important value
could be multiple values so long as
they're all tied together in some
kind of system and when you realize
what nietzsche called the devaluation of
values namely that these values don't
really
hold up when you've been say betrayed by
the cause that you
bought into and sold everything for and
put your reputation on the line for
and then found out that they were just
as bad as everybody else or just as
venial or corrupt
it's easy to slip into a kind of
nihilism
when you are the you know great example
of this
when you're the the buy-in person
who says oh if i just act like a good
boy or a nice girl within the system
and do what's expected of me i'll be
rewarded and then you find out that it
doesn't really work that way people get
as we say burnt out and then they start
doing all sorts of other things they
swing to the other extreme and become a
bad boy
right um for a little while and that
might be a form of nihilism so
seriousness you know thinking that there
should be something that i can i can
believe in i can
take for granted i can at least you know
make my stand on this point and i'll
everything will be okay turns out that's
not the case
that drive gets turned back in on itself
and she talks about the the neolis as
reading themselves of the anxiety of
freedom by denying the world
and themselves and over and over again
she stresses that
this denial is not really possible
in a full sense that there's always a
certain hidden positivity
and determinateness within nihilism
so you know she says he wants to be
nothing and this nothing that he dreams
of is still another kind of being
the exact hegelian antithesis of being a
stationary datum
nihilism has disappointed seriousness
turned back on itself a choice
of this kind is not encountered among
those who feeling the joy of existence
assume it's gratuity
it appears either at the moment of
adolescence when the individual seeing
his
child's universe flows away feels the
lack in his heart or later on
when the attempts to fulfill himself as
a being have failed
in any case among people who wish to rid
themselves of the anxiety of their
freedom
and she says by this rejection they draw
close to the
sub-human but they're not the sub-human
they're a different type
because they're continually engaged in
this process
of negating and
before looking at the different modes
which is where she goes next
talking about for example bald lair we
should look at the relationship
and the contrast between her form of
existentialism
and nihilism so a little bit earlier
right she said that they they instead of
realizing their negativity as a living
moment
movement rather uh this person conceives
their annihilation in a substantial way
right what does this mean realizing
their negativity is a living movement it
means
embracing the world and oneself
as you might say unfinished things
that we have to take an active role in
determining
and we have to do so on the basis of a
freedom that is afforded to us
and a you know this existentialist sort
of primal upsurge
into being that we are responsible for
our facticity
so instead of that the
the nihilist wants to annihilate things
annihilate the world annihilate
themselves annihilate values
in some sort of substantive way they
could have gone
a different way she also talks a little
bit later about this
will to negation and she says that it's
always
beliying itself that means it's showing
itself to be false
why because it manifests itself as a
presence at the very moment it displays
itself
and then she says here's a very
interesting idea
it implies a constant tension right
attention means that there's
some sort of unresolved thing and
there's there's polarities to it
and they both are but they can't be made
entirely compatible so what's really
interesting is she says
that this is a tension inversely
symmetrical with the
existential and more painful
tension why why is it connected with the
existential tension and
why is it inverse to it so she says if
it's true that the human being is not
it's also true that they exist and in
order to realize their negative
negativity positively he will have to
contradict
constantly the movement of existence
so the the nihilist
is attempting to deny
the you could call it the existentialist
conception of the human condition
and to slip into something else instead
but there's still a
tension there so long as they remain
alive
because they're negating can't ever be a
full negation
there's also this discussion about
defining the human as a lack at the
heart of the existence
so you know she goes on she says there's
a certain truth to the nihilist attitude
we experience the ambiguity of the human
condition
but the mistake is that the
nihilist attitude defines the human
being not as the positive existence of
the lack which is what the
existentialists are saying right
so positive existence of
something that is negative a lack a lack
of
being we are not simply objects we as
consciousnesses
are a negativity that is
at the same time also a you know this is
going to sound paradoxical
a positivity of that very negativity or
like a registering of it
so the the nihilist instead experience
defines the human being as a lack
at the heart of existence and she says
the truth is that existence is not a
lack as such and
if freedom is experienced in the case of
the form of rejection it's not
genuinely fulfilled the freedom
the negativity involved in freedom that
we have is a different sort of
negativity
as that involved in simply rejection and
negation
or tearing down you could say that if we
want to use technical terms here the
existentialists
like sartre de bevoir and they're also
taking this from heidegger
talk about neolating uh comportments
the the um nihilist is restricting
themselves to just a certain set of
neolithic
comportments right and interestingly
rejecting the rest
or denying the rest so there's actually
something quite complicated
here and she goes on further and this is
a little bit easier to
to to wrap your head around i think
because it's more moral than
metaphysical she says
that the problem with nihilism is that
it remains
at this um realization
that the world lacks justification and
that a human being strictly speaking
is not you know anything they they are
in a certain respect a nothing so she
says
um what they're forgetting is that it's
up to the human being
after that realization to justify the
world and to make themselves
exist validly so existentialism
doesn't just stop with this realization
that any value that we pick
we're the ones picking it there is no
ultimate justification
for why we picked this one over this one
we have to take responsibility for that
so the existentialist as opposed to the
nihilist says okay
let me pick on the best basis i can
let me be responsible for this whereas
the nila says oh it's all [ __ ] it's
all bad
none of it's any good none of it lives
up to what the serious person wanted
and that's a fundamental mistake on
their part so the annihilus
kind of goes partly down the
existentialist path and then goes
off into whatever the nothing is that
they're
aiming at whereas the existentialist
moves ahead
like she says the fundamental fault of
the nihilist is that
challenging all given values he does not
find beyond their ruin
the importance of that universal
absolute end
what is that for the existentialist
which freedom itself
is freedom itself
is the end is the
value for dubawar
in the ethics of ambiguity and for
existentialists in
in general there can be other values as
well but that is a
central part of existentialism at least
as
you know many influential
existentialists understand it and so the
nihilist is in certain respects
not going far enough they're stopping
short
and remaining within a position that
while
true in a certain respect turns into a
falsehood when you just stay there now
she talks about several different
modes of this and i think that this is a
decent analysis i wouldn't say that it's
a comprehensive
analysis of all the different possible
modes but some of these are
quite uh important she talks about this
rejection
of the serious world while maintaining
the serious world as what you're
rejecting
and she uses bold lair as a prime
example of this
if you've never read boldlair you really
should because his poetry is is
pretty awesome but there is this this
tendency within his work
like she says bald lair felt a burning
rancor in regard to the values of his
childhood but this rancor still involves
some respect
scorn alone liberated him it was
necessary
that this universe which he rejected
continue
in order for him to detest and scoff at
it you can't
keep you can't you have to have it there
to reject you can't
have this attitude without maintaining
the thing
that you're saying no to so there's
there's a kind of you know
inauthenticity to that even though
you're living out a very unconventional
lifestyle
she also talks about the demoniacle man
uh saying they're very close to the
serious they want to believe in it they
confirm it by their by their very revolt
they feel themselves as a negation and a
freedom but they don't realize this
freedom as a positive
liberation and you know we can see uh
discussions of the demoniacle in for
example kierkegaard
and dostoevsky in in all sorts of other
authors going further she says you can
annihilate the rejected world and
the self and there are a number of
different ways in which people do this
concretely
she gives a few really interesting
examples here
the person who gives themselves to a
cause which they know
to be lost chooses to merge
the world with one of its aspects which
carries within it the germ of its ruin
involving himself in this condemned
universe and condemning himself
with it we could often call this the
tragic figure right the person who
the the loser who you know realizes
that they they they just can't win the
world is against them
but they're going to fight against it
anyway that can be nihilistic
she's got another example another person
devotes his time and energy to an
undertaking which was
not doomed to failure at the start but
which
he himself is bent on ruining
now project there could be all sorts of
things becoming rich
and then handicapping oneself along the
way
sabotaging oneself we often say the
project could also be
relational it could be a marriage
it could be parenthood it could be
becoming a better person oneself right
through some sort of program
but this person is always undermining
themselves because they don't really
want the project to succeed another
she says rejects each of their projects
one after the other
frittering them away in a series of
caprices
thereby systematically annoying the ends
at which they're aiming at the person
who moves
from project to project to project or
within sub projects you could say and
never really gets
anything done never really finishes
what they intended to do because they
found something else that that's cool
now in our world and also in her time as
well
there are entire industries that cater
to this
aren't there i mean she brought up a
little bit earlier in the book
the woman of fashion the fashion
industry
is all about that now the individual
designers
are seeing things through but the person
who is
putting together an ensemble you know to
make their life finally
complete it's it's an endless project
she
devoir talks about the dadas
dadaists right and she says the constant
negation of the word by the word of the
act by the art of art by art was
realized
by da dust in coherence following a
strict injunction to commit disorder and
anarchy
you thereby achieve the abolition of all
behavior and there of all
ends in itself she also talks about the
destruction of the self
through physical suicide there's other
longer ways to do this she talks about
destroying their bodies ruining their
mind by drugs you could do this just as
well with alcohol
right others succeeded in a kind of
moral suicide
she said they found themselves in a
desert reduced to the level of the sub
man so that's another possibility she
also brings up those who
leave the nihilist attitude by seeking
out the security of the
serious and we don't really need to say
that much about
them they they just become a serious
person right and they're in that dynamic
but she does talk about the erection
of a new kind of ethics and ethics of
negativity
she says the negation of aesthetic
spiritual and moral values
has become an ethics unruliness has
become a rule
we've been present at the establishment
of a new church with its dogmas rights
faithful priests even its martyrs
she says there's nothing of the
destroyer in breton he is a pope meaning
he's pronouncing and people are
following
and she says that you know the
surrealists themselves
fit into this uh as well you can only go
so far
with saying no all the time with
rejecting with subverting with doing all
these
negative behaviors finally
she talks about another thing that's
that's
very important she brings up the nazis
as an example of this
nihilism can also lead into a desire for
power because if it's all if we're going
to take this cynical attitude it's all
bs
everybody's just screwing each other
over nothing really matters
well some people said why shouldn't i
get rich and others would say well
being rich is cool being you know famous
is cool
power seems to be something that is
still there
is still attractive that i could aim at
and then when you get it you find out
it's not everything that you thought it
was
it's not as good and then you can be
nihilistic again
and so this can be a desire for power a
desire for
destruction for seeing the effects of
what one does
she brings up the uh author drew
la rochelle and talks about
in his hatred of himself he chose to
reject his condition
as a human being this led him to hate
all other people along with themselves
he knows satisfaction only when he fires
on spanish workers
and sees the flow of blood the only
salvation
is the death of other men by which
perfect negation
is achieved and then drew to la rochelle
who was actually a collaborator with the
nazi regime kills himself
in the end so there's a lot of different
modes
a lot of different ways of partially
denying one's freedom not taking
responsibility
for the the negative within the human
being that is
is there that that does have to be
addressed
and so she thinks that existentialism
instead
making freedom the the prime value and
taking responsibility for it
is the way the the best way out of
nihilism rather than
lapsing into the sub-person relaxing
into the serious or following nihilism
through
to its end so nihilism is also an
inauthentic
mode of existence for de bevoir
you